what's the doctor without his companions
[Music]
I am claiming to in the not so distant
future revisit my ranking of modern era
Doctor Who companions but before I do
that I kind of wanted to talk about how
the companion dr. dynamic has changed
mostly what I talk about this I'm
talking about classic era versus modern
era now I've alluded to some of this
before when I talked about some of the
major differences between classic and
modern and I sort of went down a number
of things and I did bring up the
companion doctor relationship but I
really kind of want to drill into that a
little bit more specifically at this
point because it's not just the nature
of the relationships between the doctor
and the companions the campaign's
themselves function different
differently as characters than they used
to the companion originally in Doctor
Who was basically just what the name of
light actually they've wanted to call
companions for a long time they were
usually referred to as assistants if
they were referred to you know by any
kind of title at all so their role was
to be there on the adventure to be
someone for the doctor to talk to to be
an extra helping hand to ask the
questions that maybe gets the doctor
thinking about things from the angle he
needs to to move things forward
you know varies from command to
companion but their time was was almost
always really just limited to while they
were on the TARDIS classic era
companions we really didn't know much at
all about their home life their family
history what things are like for them
back home it was just something the
original show didn't deal much it knew
who deals with it a lot and it's not
that's not a
bad thing I actually initially was one
of the things that sort of distinguished
it from classic era was it drilled much
more into the companions as characters
that's not to say that they weren't
fully formed characters in classic Terra
but they didn't have the same level of
backstory we got like a couple of
highlight points like we know ace hates
her mother you know we know Jamie you
know being Islander he's very gung-ho
and and ready for a fight you've got
Adric with his keen mathematics skills
you know you've got a couple of traits
but then we're just seeing them
basically on the job and you know seeing
how they gathering when we came from
them based on how they react to the
doctor in the situation's they're put in
we get much more backstory these days
and sometimes that works sometimes that
doesn't I've gone on record as saying
I'm not a huge fan of the domestics of
how much of the home life we see of the
various companions at this point and
honestly I think this part of the reason
I like to bill as much as I did because
bill didn't have a ton of ties to earth
to this era I mean we kept coming back
to it annoyingly but she we didn't that
she didn't have to keep checking in with
family and recurring friend characters
in a significant other she felt much
more like a classic era companion in
that she was just traveling with the
doctor on various adventures but aside
from her most of them we get quite a bit
of family dynamics and Rose was a little
bit mixed for me in that department I
found Jackie to be kind of irritating I
did like Mickey though as a character
especially the way he developed with
Martha her family was not always there
but when they were there they were
pretty heavy focus which wasn't a bad
way to handle it Donna
loved her family you know you see her
mother you get a lot of white Donna is
the way she is and then Wilf
I gotta love Bernard Cribbins so it's re
Bernhard Cribbins I guess is the way it
would be correctly pronounced for my
British subscribers but him as Wolff is
he's astounding is amazing I love him
both his relationship with Donna and as
a character and then we get into the
Moffatt era and I like Amy and not only
that I like Amy and Rory's relationships
and I do like that we didn't get a ton
of additional you know family back I
think that was one of the things that
bugged me about save Rose is we got all
this extra family baggage or at least it
felt like we did you know having to keep
checking in with her mother and her
boyfriend and her alternate-universe dad
whereas with Amy it was really just Rory
and we got to see that relationship
belong I think that worked I don't know
why we touched base with Clara's family
the couple times that we did like I
legitimately don't know why that was
done and God the other when she when she
was babysitting or nanny or whatever she
was to those kids
um I actually like Danny pink better
than a lot of people do but it's not
handled as well as say Rory and Amy were
and then as I said bill that's one of
the things I like about her
it looked like a classic classic error
though the whole idea of the doctor
having to come back and pick up the
companion like the companion just living
in their own place on earth and the
doctor coming to get them to go on an
adventure that was never really the case
in classic who in classic Who companion
traveled with the doctor pretty much
continuously either because the TARDIS
is really obnoxious about going where
the doctor wants it to go and it takes
him forever to take them back home or
they travel until they choose to stop
there are exceptions of course
especially when you're talking about
the Third Doctor's era where he was
earthbound for a decent chunk of that
but by and large that was how it worked
I think really though the biggest way in
which things have shifted is how
significant the doctor is in the lives
of these companions now that's not to
say that the doctor was not significant
to the lives of companions in classic
era more that is just something that the
show never really dealt with you know
most of the Companions chose when they
were gonna stop traveling with the
doctor they in some way communicated to
him okay I'm done I've had enough and he
drops them off and that's it again a
couple of exceptions in the case of his
granddaughter Susan he made the choice
for her cuz you could see that she was
kind of torn up by it every now and then
he had a character who left
involuntarily possibly by death you know
with folks like a drinker it didn't even
have to be that you know Sarah Jane
Smith didn't choose when she left
because the doctor got called to
Gallifrey and she couldn't go with him
there so that was that for her it wasn't
the time that she chose to leave and so
you've got a few things like that but by
and large characters say okay doctor I'm
done now and he drops them off and often
with a melancholy to him but you know he
drops them off he has his little moment
about that and he moves along and the
persona the presumption at least that I
get the sense of was that the Companions
kind of did the same you know it's it's
like it's like going on a on a whirlwind
you know European travelogue with
somebody and once you're done you go
well thanks for that you go home and you
live your life and you always remember
it was you know it may have been a
really pivotal point in your life but
you know you move on and you do other
things how
crucial the doctor becomes to the lives
of companions it seems to have been
ramped up quite a bit in modern era to
the point that we've only really had one
companion choose to leave the TARDIS
that was Martha
pretty much everybody else has been
forced out by circumstance you know Rose
got stuck in the end the alternate
dimension Donna had to get her mind
wiped Amy and Rory died kind of sort of
eventually of old age but you know they
that wasn't their choice for timing for
when to leave Clara died and she didn't
but whatever and then you know bill died
basically and and you know and nardole
got got left behind so they've made the
connection between the doctor and the
Kamiya is so strong that they they the
writers seem to have become unwilling to
believe that someone would ever choose
to not continue to travel with the
doctor forever so they have to force
circumstances to allow for the companion
to leave or the force that khomeini
leave more accurately and I'm not saying
that any or even all of the ways in
which the companions have been removed
in modern era is bad but I do think it's
an upshot of something that happens when
and and I might do a future video on
this because because it impacts more
than just Doctor Who but I think it's an
upshot of something that happens when
you have fans of something writing it
because when you have writers who grew
up watching Doctor Who and like EDD
themselves as kids wanting to travel
with the doctor they can't imagine why
anyone would want to stop therefore they
don't really know how to write someone
wanting to stop so instead they write
them being forced to stop and that again
does really jack up the intensity of the
connection that companions have and kind
of making it the most important thing
they will ever do in their own lives and
I don't mean like on a galactic scale
because it probably is but you know
these people theoretically could still
do things that that for themselves
matter more than traveling with a doctor
and modern Aero doctor who has even kind
of gone back and retroactively lis done
that to some of the past companions we
got that a bit with Sarah Jane Smith
because she came back and she was kind
of ticked at him further for leaving her
and she says how there was basically no
one else and she never found that same
kind of excitement in her life again now
with Sarah Jane I do think that if you
were gonna do that with the past
campaign yet that one makes a lot of
sense because she like I said didn't get
to choose to leave but then if you watch
the Sarah Jane Adventures they did it
with Joe Grant too and if there's a
companion that you shouldn't pull that I
will I was always looking for you I was
always hoping to travel with you again
angle it's Joe Grant because she she
left to get married she made a choice in
her life for somebody else and the way
that the Sarah Jane Adventures has her
interact with Matt Smith's doctor kind
of undermines that choice and shades it
as if not a mistake at the very least as
more conflicted than I think it was
originally intended to be so it's it's
something that I'd have a
you know brought up when I've talked
about things that dr. who needs to stop
doing and whatnot because I this is
something that is a little bit more
nebulous than things like the companion
template you know the the usually young
female from modern-day England which I'm
so sick of I mean that I can nail down
and make punchy and make as part of a
list but the shift in dynamic with the
with the companions and making them
making the doctor so central to their
lives and making them so central to his
because the doctor always appreciated
his companions but they've really made
them into like the doctor is incomplete
without them to the point that certain
writers feel they are justified in doing
things like what went on in hell bent so
the the strength of that relationship
has just gone up severely and in a way
that I feel is starting to hamper the
show a little bit but unfortunately it's
also something that I don't know if
there's a way to roll it back because
well I'll revise that you can have you
could probably have companions who don't
feel like the doctor is the only thing
they have going on in their lives or
will you know never do anything to rival
their time with him you can certainly
they could write companions like that I
think it would be really hard to ever
roll back the doctors new level of
dependency on the guy I mean naked
dependency I think you know naked
blatant which I'd chosen different word
of the naked now I'm just gonna say
naked again because I don't know it's
weird that I'm saying naked in any case
it's now really blatant and it was in
the classic era but it was much more of
an undercurrent that he needs the
Companions now it's really friend Center
I think it's gonna be really hard to
rollback that end of it of the doctors
need for them be
because I'm not sure how you do that
without in a way undermining whoever the
most recent opinion is because it's like
oh well he obviously doesn't care about
them the way that the doctor previously
cared about someone like bill or Clara
or Rose or Donna or what-have-you
so that unfortunate is a movie we might
be somewhat I mean I say unfortunately
because I bet this is this is a this is
a ship that like is that I feel is
hamstringing the narrative a bit because
since it's difficult to dial back the
doctors dependency on companions and at
least so far showrunners have been
unwilling to dial back the companions
dependency on the doctor from what
they've built it up to over the last ten
series then an unfortunate becomes
repetitive you know the first couple of
tragic departures for new era doctor who
were in fact that you know rose in
doomsday that was tragic
donna in journey's end that was tragic I
didn't hit me quite as hard but I know a
lot of people got really choked up but
angels in Manhattan with Amy and Rory
but it's become just another thing that
happens the companion travels until
something tragic happens and I feel like
we need to show a companion who is you
know functional enough as you know as an
independent entity to know when they're
good and when they're done and we need
the doctor to be able to process a
breakup not look not a tragedy not a
loss just effectively a breakup and I
think that would be something that would
that I'd like to see happen with the
next companions except we've got three
commands so how much you want to bet one
of them leave voluntarily one of them
dies I don't know
into the third we'll forget about the
third because three too many it may not
be I don't know we'll see so that's kind
of my not really building to a specific
point ramble about the ways in which the
doctor companion relationship have
changed over time and sort of singling
out the some of the specifics on that
because it's something and like I said
I've alluded to before and I really
wanted to drill in on so that's it for
this one what do you think about the way
that the doctor companion relationship
is handled in modern area do you prefer
how it was done in classic do you like
the way modern does it do you want to
see it shake and I'm pretending from the
way it's been done the last as I said
ten series or so whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do you support me on patreon
follow me on Twitter I got a podcast bla
bla bla bla bla
links for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is your
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]